[Music]
on this Saturday night a call for help
from Canadian businesses we won't be
able to last through June will small and
medium companies be able to pay the rent
while shut down the tension in the u.s.
to reopen the American economy plus
privacy versus public health this is not
a sort of behind your back Big Brother
sort of thing should Canada have
tracking devices to monitor the
quarantine and finding companionship
during the Cova 19 crisis
[Music]
global national with Robin Gill good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin tonight with the strain on small
businesses during this pandemic
according to the Canadian Federation of
Independent businesses 80% of small
companies are completely or partially
closed in order to stop the spread of
Kovan 19 rent is the second highest cost
after wages for those entrepreneurs but
with little to no money coming in it's
getting harder for them to pay their
bills today the Prime Minister said he's
aware of the issue but warned opening
things up too soon could come at a
greater cost Mike delay reports we are
being very very careful in how we move
forward as a country there's no gray
area in Justin Trudeau's daily address
Canada is not ready to reopen the border
despite comments from Donald Trump
hinting restrictions could ease sooner
than later is closed and will remain so
until kovat 19 is under control if we
reopen too quickly or too soon or in the
wrong way we could find ourselves back
in this situation a couple of months
from now and everything everything we
will have sacrificed during these months
will have been for not facing increased
pressure to jumpstart the economy
Trudeau announced a 306 million dollars
in interest-free loans and non repayable
contributions to help keep indigenous
businesses afloat it comes after Ottawa
announced it was looking into a program
to help small and medium sized
businesses pay their rent relief can't
come soon enough for do it right fitness
for women in Whitby Ontario whose owners
stopped taking membership dues when they
were forced to close yet are still
paying fifty three hundred dollars a
month rent money that is coming out of
their savings probably another few
months if we're if we're having to
continue to pay rent full we won't be
able to last through June July the
summer will be will be closed
the program puts the onus on landlords
to give imperiled businesses a lifeline
which not all are doing this Danforth
restaurant is now closed a sign on the
door reads the landlord has taken
possession of this store for non-payment
of rent and more could be coming a
survey by the Canadian Federation of
Independent businesses found that 22% of
its members had zero income coming in
while half say they won't survive
another month what I'm nervous about is
just digging myself a hole that I'm not
able to get us out of the provinces have
jurisdiction over rent and the
relationship between landlords and
tenants but Trudeau says he's had recent
meetings with industry groups and
provincial leaders to see if a solution
can be found with rent due in less than
two weeks the clock is ticking micro
like Global News Toronto many of the
cases in Canada have come from those
returning from the US it has more
confirmed cases and deaths from Cova 19
than any other country in the world more
than seven hundred and thirty thousand
Americans have tested positive for the
virus at least 38,000 have died despite
the worsening situation many Americans
are desperate to get back to normal life
and as Jennifer Johnson explains today
hundreds of them took to the streets
protestors circling the State Capitol
and governor's mansion in Annapolis
Maryland joining a growing chorus of
angry Americans desperate to get back to
work but in hard-hit New York this
governor like many others is torn
between protecting his citizens and
protecting his economy nobody wants to
reopen more than me nobody wants to get
the economy going more than me stay at
home orders vary from state to state a
couple of Governors will live theirs as
early as Monday Texas and Vermont will
allow certain businesses to open on
Monday while still requiring appropriate
social distancing health officials
warning there may be enough Kovan 19
tests for the beginning phase a
president Donald Trump's three-part plan
to reopen businesses and restore the
economy but not beyond that if these
things are done correctly what I believe
they can we will have and there will be
enough
to allow us to take this country safely
through phase 1 a risky move as many
states are still seeing a rise in cases
nursing homes are being overrun so many
health care workers and patients getting
sick the National Guard has been called
in to help nearly half of the centers
are reporting staffing shortages we need
the protective gear that we should have
to take care of these residents we have
children we have we have our own family
to go home to the economic toll from
koban 19 is also harming millions food
banks are running out of supplies the US
Department of Agriculture is now rolling
out a 19 billion dollar relief program
buying food from farmers and getting it
to food banks this program means that we
get to eat today the nation's food
supply is dwindling as meat poultry and
pork processing plants have shut down in
South Dakota Iowa Colorado and other
states because so many workers have been
infected
Annie grant died of the virus after
working at this Georgia food processing
plant she had been on the packing line
for nearly 15 years we don't come we
don't get paid or we're getting fired
and she has go the threat of the virus
versus the threat of being unemployed
bills are piling up America caught in
the crosshairs of the pandemic and an
economic crisis and no immediate cure
for either Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington
let's look at the picture across Canada
now more than 1,400 people have died
from Kovan 19 confirmed cases of now
surpassed 33 thousand more than half a
million tests have been done with six
percent of them coming back as confirmed
cases dr. Tam said that there is some
cause for cautious optimism coming from
the data this still holds true but we
must remain vigilant stay focused and
keep our eyes on the ultimate goal which
is limiting the spread of this terrible
virus most of the deaths in Canada are
in Quebec inside long-term care homes
quebec's premier has described the
situation as a national
urgency and tonight the province is
receiving help from the federal
government as Dan Spectre explains
members of the Canadian Armed Forces are
now coming to the rescue a surreal but
welcome sight members of the Canadian
Armed Forces are now deployed to a
public long-term care residents in
Montreal people were clapping listen
this situation is so dire that people
need help lieutenant commander Heather
Galbraith is one of a hundred Canadian
Forces medical personnel fanning out to
Quebec seniors homes she's a trained
family doctor who grew up in Sudbury
Ontario we are essentially doing what we
call in the Army and Navy and Air Force
a recce so a reconnaissance of what
needs are required this is the second
seniors home before tsa's assess the son
hada Benjamin Yvonne brunette has a
hundred and five cases of copán 19 more
than half its residents even if it's the
army or doctors or anybody and I'm happy
there's some help there
we have training packages that are being
rolled out a lot of that will be learned
on the job as well so far the forces are
focusing on five residences in Montreal
but the needs are widespread Manila is
now in the prison on Twitch so Matt out
there unfortunately many of our staff
are sick they have COBIT 19 says this
health official crews and long-term care
facilities can't keep up with demand to
deal with some basic needs of seniors
like feeding and changing diapers
Canadian soldiers are stepping up
absolutely
our teams will do whatever we can and
there's another type of reinforcements
on the way to Montreal seniors
residences specifically those in the
western portion of the island we're
training our new staff volunteers and
other people anyone that volunteered
really health authorities in Montreal's
West Island have partnered with the Red
Cross to give volunteers crash courses
to help out in seniors homes power of
humanity that we usually send outside of
Canada to countries that are really in
deep needs now we are bringing it home
they have the capacity to train 40
people a day part of this hotel has
become a makeshift training center
officials hope lots of people will turn
out because the battle is far from over
Dan Specter Global News Montreal
concerns at an Alberta long-term care
home have prompted the provinces health
authority to take over its operations
Alberta Health Services is now managing
manoir Duloc a care home about four
hours northwest of Edmonton at least 26
residents and 11 staff have tested
positive for Kovan 19:5 residents have
died Alberta's chief medical officer of
Health says the province took over
because of several concerns including
inadequate screening a lack of staff and
failure to meet care standards family
members with loved ones in the home were
surprised to learn about the problems
it's not a good situation to be honest
and now a lot of the other staff are in
jeopardy and the residents especially
and hopefully things get taken care of
the company that was managing the care
home says it was following protocols to
the best of its ability meanwhile
Ontario reiterated it has no intention
of taking over care homes that have
covered 19 outbreaks instead the
provinces coordinating plans with the
facilities with every announcement about
changes to the financial programs rolled
out in Ottawa we hear about thousands of
Canadians who are left out
Abigail Beeman tells us about the
changes some people are calling for and
why help is so badly needed especially
among the nation's most vulnerable
Walter Cole was already homeless then he
lost his job as a cleaner due to cope in
nineteen
I'd like to go back to work life for him
at the Ottawa mission shelter has
changed new rules around cleaning and
trying to enforce physical distancing
not easy among the homeless Cole is not
worried about getting sick
not one bit because you know why all
three shelters nobody's got it so and it
this place is so clean but fear keep
staff on high alert every call it's oh
is this the one is this the first
positive test because we know we're in
an enclosed environment and what a risk
that would bring Peter Tilley says some
of the two hundred million dollars
promised by the federal government for
the homeless has trickled down to his
shelter but more is needed and the
homeless are just one vulnerable
population we're hoped it doesn't matter
which way you look at it we are
absolutely subedi was laid off due to
kovat nineteen so she would be eligible
for the CRB but like thousands of
Canadians she's worried if she applies
she'll lose her provincial disability
benefit BC was the first province to be
clear it wouldn't do that it's so wrong
on every single level it seems everybody
except the vulnerable are being looked
after and it really should be the other
way around or at least equal you could
well see a dollar-for-dollar clawback so
you could apply for serve and then
realise at the end of the month that
your disability payment you thought was
going to be $1,000 $1,500 is now zero
because you apply to the emergency
benefit the Canadian Center for Policy
Alternatives has been tracking who falls
through the cracks even with this week's
expansion of the program dave MacDonald
says there are about 800,000 Canadians
who can't get the CRB or a I and he says
youth were hit especially hard a third
of all youth that were employed in
February either lost their job or lost
the majority of their hours in March
shaylen Harnish is behind this petition
to expand the CRB to include students
and new graduates the single mom and
full-time student has no idea whether
she can afford to go back to the
classroom this
all we feel left behind and we're
looking for support if we could work
we'd rather work but yeah with millions
of Canadians feeling the same way
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa coming
up what one famous city in Italy looks
like now compared to a year ago
the world is watching just how fast Cova
19 is spreading around the globe tonight
there are more than 2.2 million cases of
Cova 19 globally and more than one
hundred and fifty-seven thousand people
have died the United States has the most
deaths of any country more than 38,000
people have died there in Italy 23,000
people are dead the second highest death
toll of any country and in Spain more
than 20,000 people have died from covin
19 hopes the UK was beginning to see its
deadly curve flattening out have been
dashed after recording its fourth worst
daily death toll since the pandemic
began more than 800 people died in the
UK in the last 24 hours and that brings
the total number of deaths connected to
Cova 19 to more than 15,000 because of
Britain's crisis Queen Elizabeth has
canceled the Royal gun salutes to mark
her birthday the monarch turns 94
Tuesday and there will be no celebration
this will be the first time in the
Queen's 68 year reign that the Royal
tradition has been called off two photos
shot from space a year apart showed the
impact Italy's nationwide lockdown has
had on waterways in Venice the European
Space Agency released this image of what
a famous Lagoon looked like just over a
year ago normally packed with tourists
cruise ships and people out enjoying the
sea breeze but a year later and since
the lockdown went into effect on March
20th there's been a huge reduction in
boat traffic and no doubt pollution
still ahead the tracking device that is
being tested to make sure people aren't
breaking quarantine
China has again revised the death toll
from Cova 19 and it went up again China
says nearly 1300 people were not counted
as victims of the deadly virus because
of lapses and delays China's death toll
now stands at more than 4,600 people
Catholics births had feared China was
under reporting cases of covin 19 but
Beijing claims there is no cover-up an
experiment with a Canadian connection is
taking place in Hong Kong residents and
visitors arriving at the airport are
being given monitoring bracelets to make
sure they're staying in quarantine a
Vancouver company is behind the
surveillance devices but there's also a
legal test fitting privacy against
public health Hong Kong was one of the
early hotspots for the new coronavirus
that government immediately implemented
quarantine measures for residents and
visitors arriving at the airport that
included these monitoring bracelets to
stop people from leaving their homes as
soon as you get out the house and then
we get alert and and health care or the
police would come catch you and any it
would be up to six months the wristbands
are like Hospital bracelets each one has
a Bluetooth module and battery those
under quarantine have to download the
app once at home they walk around so the
app can calibrate how big the home is
with the wristband so this could be some
ones that Customs and Border Patrol or
Health Authority a Vancouver company
Tracey is behind the technology and the
Chinese territory is its first test case
there's a thin piece of metal that goes
all the way around the bracelet that
actually provides an alert if it's cut
or stretched so there are tamper
resistant pieces to the design CEO Wayne
Lloyd is pitching the devices to other
governments including Canada but in this
country it would have to pass a
constitutional test that balances
privacy rights with Public Health to put
bracelets on people under any
circumstances would require that a law
be passed and
I do not believe that the emergency
management powers allow either federal
or provincial legislatures to do that
right now
Hong Kong supposedly had 20,000
bracelets ready at airport arrivals but
not everyone received one I think one
big problem is that they really didn't
have a chance to test run the whole
system before it goes out Tracy is
working out the kinks so to speak but
feels this is the way to get out of
lockdown faster once the tracking is
over you cut the bracelet off and it's
done this is not a a sort of behind your
back Big Brother sort of thing still the
concern over Big Brother may explain why
Canada is relying on the conscience of
Canadians to prevent communities spread
of this silent killer
doctors in Japan are warning that the
country's medical system could collapse
amid a wave of nuke ovid 19 cases Japan
initially appeared to have the virus
under control but now there are more
than 10,000 confirmed cases of Cova 19
in the country
health officials say emergency rooms
have been unable to treat some patients
with serious health conditions because
of the extra burden caused by the virus
pandemic pets how our time staying home
is helping more animals find homes
that's next
we've all been spending a lot more time
at home this past month seeing our
friends on screens instead of in person
animal shelters are seeing a huge
increase in the number of people looking
to adopt or foster a pet to deal with
the loneliness from Cova 19 it was
Reggie Cecchini the need to find these
animals a forever home has run up
against a world stuck at home as the
copic 19 pandemic leaves shelters
struggle to keep their doors open the
staff person goes down with kovat then
what does that mean for the team that
they've got in place to deal with the
frontline care inside the shelter to
ease the burden a call was put out
asking people to open their hearts and
their homes in southwestern Ontario
Lincoln County Humane Society they put
out their normal call for usually about
20 Foster's 400 people responded in
Canada foster rates are 40 to 70 percent
higher now than the same time last year
and it's a story that's playing out
across the continent we've seen the
biggest uptick in people that want to
foster animals during the time when
they're working from home in times of
high stress a four-legged friend can
provide a much needed distraction and
have a way of keeping us grounded the
fact that pets really live in the moment
um sort of reinforces that that's what
we should be doing right now studies
have shown that pets have a positive
impact on our health helping the
decrease blood pressure lower
cholesterol and reduced loneliness but
the furry friends families are bringing
into their homes are also experiencing
something themselves animals are highly
sensitive is what makes them such great
companions and so if you have high
amount of stress in your life right now
your animals probably sensing it amidst
a health crisis comes a learning
opportunity for families and their
foster pets to explore each other
surroundings and feelings this crisis is
demonstrating to us just how important
our animals are you know you see all
kinds of hashtags coming up about new
co-workers and working at home with pets
once again proving pets can provide
unconditional love we definitely see the
strength of the human animal bond
no matter how uncertain the times regi
Cecchini global news Washington we've
seen an outpouring of support for health
care workers who are on the front lines
of this pandemic fight tonight there
will be another demonstration of that
gratitude a virtual concert right here
on global and airing around the world is
called one world together at home it's
not a telethon the tab has been picked
up by philanthropists the corporate
sector broadcasters and entertainers the
show is being curated by Lady gaga
who will also perform other stars
include Elton John Billie Eilish
Taylor Swift and the Rolling Stones the
two hour broadcast of one world together
at home airs on Global TV tonight you
can check your local listings for times
and that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill one of the
Canadians taking part of that fundraiser
is Rufus Wainwright but it's not the
only show the Montreal born musician has
in store
[Music]
it's day 33 for corn toons Wainwright's
daily robe recitals streamed from his
living room thank you for watching good
night
[Music]